[Musique]
bienvenue dans cette nouvelle édition de
envies de lecture nathalie wolf
bonjour tu vas pas dans une lecture sans
merci à toi alors on est dans une époque
un peu de désillusions de repli sur soi
ptom dacquois bunnies mais justement on
reçoit quelqu'un qui nous dit pas tout
faire tout le contraire aux et
l'engagement osez vous engagez c'est
benjamin d'abonnés dit bonjour bonjour
patrice c'est donc votre mix appel aux
dons l'engagement lettre ouverte à
emmanuel macron pour en parler c'est au
aux éditions faut peut-être que nous
présenter le père saisit alors viens
vous êtes docteur en droit
arrive alors vous avez travaillé bon
papa quand fonctionnaires mais pour les
services du premier ministre et vous
êtes actuellement président de
l'observatoire des corps intermédiaires
et vous avez publié via lee a un nom ce
livre le retour des corps intermédiaires
part également aux éditions fauves dans
lequel vous insistiez déjà sur ce besoin
d'engagements dont on va parler dans
dans un instant mais peut-être et avant
d'aller plus loin sur l'engagement parce
qu'on est quand même au lendemain de ces
élections régionales et départementales
avec une abstention record entre
millions pendant millions de français ne
sont pas allés aux urnes ce qui est
énorme alors est ce que justement ça ne
marque pas que nos sociétés attendent
cette actuelle on a plutôt un
désengagement qu'un engagement avec
cette idée en particulier pour les pour
les jeunes que toute cette vie
collective la politique la
représentation tout ça les concerne pas
et donc en soi mais ce que vous ne venez
pas un combat d'arrière-garde
merci alors est-ce que je vous lis reste
c'est que le corps électoral français
patrice disaient qu'ils avaient 35 noms
de deux français voudraient aller voter
mais il ya 48 millions de français qui
sont inscrits sur les listes électorales
et l'engagement en france l'engagement
concret des gens au quotidien que ce
soit dans les associations parlent de
corps intermédiaires c'est une
expression un peu compliqué mais dans
les associations les fondations les
syndicats les ong les think tanks et
autres il ya 25 millions de français
engagés
je pense qu'on va bien si on met en
regard le fait qu'il ya un français sur
deux a de l'âge adulte qui est engagée
ou en français sur 3 si on prend
l'ensemble de la population
si on met ça en regard du nombre de gens
qui votent on peut se rendre compte
qu'il ya au fond une vraie envie
d'engagement mais qui peine à trouver un
débouché peut-être parmi le personnel
politique et système tel qu'il
fonctionne aujourd'hui ça c'est ma
conviction c'est oui c'est vrai qu'on
porte à prêter cette abstention va il ya
deux façons il ya tout qui lisons votre
pas parce que ça sert à rien et on peut
l'interpréter aussi pour une certaine
partie des gens qui s'abstiennent comme
une sorte d'appel au secours à plus de
démocratie peut-être plus justement de
vie collective quoi en préparant un
petit peu l'émission
j'ai eu l'occasion de retrouver le livre
que vous avez fait paraître il ya dix
ans déjà
comment perdre une élection
présidentielle puisque vous en parlez la
brouille la porte ils sont les était
presque ça et je me souviens dans le fil
rouge le fil conducteur qui était
l'autre patrice vous disiez mais comment
le personnel politique qui est sis au
fait des soubresauts de l'opinion si au
fait des analyses des sociologique les
plus poussées si au fait des remontées
d'informations du terrain et autres
comment peuvent-ils faire autant de
bévues de diam être aussi gauche au fond
même de droite alors qu'ils sont au
courant de ce qui se passe c'est au
terrain alors en fait c'est ça c'est
quelque chose que d'avoir réellement
beaucoup intéressé parce qu'on se rend
compte qu'aujourd'hui le constat qui
était un mec qui d'évidence je dirais à
l'époque vous aviez écrit à 10 ans se
livrent les corps intermédiaires dans
leur ensemble avaient une vraie vie dans
la société
mais il ya eu progressivement de façon
assez accéléré depuis françois hollande
est avec moi même à combien je pense
qu'on va y revenir une difficulté à
appréhender l'extraordinaire maillage
d'hommes et de femmes engagés sur
terrain dans le pays au quotidien qui
sont dans des actions parfois
extrêmement simples ou très courageuse
mais qui sont dans l'anonymat donc voilà
il ya ce gars là j'ai justement à
vauzelles prononcé cette expression et
qui faisait le corps de votre
premier livre si je peux dire mais dont
vous parlez aussi dans mon engagement
c'est le corps intermédiaires alors
cette définition la définition qu'on
peut donner
qu'est ce que c'est les corps
intermédiaires faut que les choses
soient claires il faut que je parle sous
l'oeil d'un professeur de philosophie
java lien n'est ce pas avec deux
conférences en droit c'est tout mais je
serais tout à fait votre équipe non mais
parce qu'elles se demandent aussi
[Rires]
franchement j'en ai la conception la
plus large possible en philosophie
politique à ce que disent les syndicats
et des associations c'est oui alors si
vous intéresse si vous interrogez c'est
vrai geoffroy roux de bézieux sur ce
plateau où il voudra les corps
intermédiaires il aura le réflexe de
dire son sont que les corps
intermédiaires syndicaux police met aux
fourneaux sa part de l'association de
quartier jusqu'à la fondation
bettencourt on sait les associations les
fondations les syndicats patronaux de
salariés c'est ce sont les pardons les
collectivités locales les communes c'est
ça au départ
l'addition de talents dans un cadre
donné territoriales qui font encore et
qui se situe au fond entre les cordes
intérieur c'est de donner une définition
je dirais que c'est tout regroupement
spontané ou délibérée de gens qui
s'organisent sur le terrain pour faire
des choses et être une espèce de maillon
intermédiaire entre les citoyens tout
seul et l'état de l'autre côté voilà
vous donner un exemple deux mesures
écoutez par exemple
je crois que vous êtes passionné de golf
j'ai pas faire l'interview à l'envers
mais vous avez fra 6 b non mais je suis
tombé sur une vidéo vous aviez fait vous
avez aidé la fédération française de
golf qui avait besoin d'y penser mais
certains messages auprès des pouvoirs
publics notamment bien pour ça on a
besoin une bonne volonté individuelle ne
compte pas beaucoup la société dont on
comprend bien qu'il ya un besoin
d'organisation qui passe par ces corps
intermédiaires pour pouvoir après
diffuser un message ce sont des lieux à
la fois de réunion de médiation entre
prêtres leurs membres et puis à
l'interlocuteur mais vraiment unique
pour le personnel politique de l'autre
côté qui en a vraiment besoin et qui
malheureusement en dehors de quelques
exceptions aujourd'hui dans les hommes
et les femmes qui font de la politique
mais pour la plupart les ont perdu de
leur leader l'ajustement dans le livre
sur les corps intermédiaires
il y avait la conclusion est écrit je
crois par françois hollande et et je
vais prendre un extrait de ski de ce
qu'il disait parce que ça replace le
débat sur justement l'engagement sur la
crise démocratique par la crise
démocratique disait la crise
démocratique de se mesure pas simplement
par les votes ou des abstentions les
manifestations les grèves ou les
mouvements c'est une crise qui porte sur
la confiance que le citoyen à cordes ou
n'accorde pas voix compte plus ou moins
pardon à leurs représentants et la cause
de cette désaffection cette
désaffiliation tient précisément à la
fatigue des corps intermédiaires à la
contestation de leur rôle et à leur
place en accord avec l'ancien président
je ne suis pas moi dans une démarche à
suivre là c'est un peu différent au
président pour le pour l'engagement
temps des tanks et de voilà de langage
est sûre il va mais comme les deux sont
liés parce que c'est aussi la crise
démocratique c'est derrière tout ça
oui avec d'ailleurs une petite renarde
de ma part c'est que emmanuel macron
avant l'élection de présidents hollande
a dans le cas de la commission
croissance de jacques attali qui avait
lié nicolas sarkozy presque théorisé
l'absence de recours au camp interdire
pour faire de la politique
donc il ya dans le monde politique il ya
des égards masse osseuse
voilà c'est tout conception et essayons
de faire sens tant qu'on peut
et puis prenant conscience que ça alors
dit peut-être un peu les processus
décisionnels qu'évidemment c'est pénible
d'avoir des syndicats qui veulent
négocier sur tel était le poids etc
mais ce sont des passages obligés dans
la respiration démocratique du pays
c'est vrai que là on revient vers
d'évoquer cette cette citation de faim
cet extrait de tirer de françois
hollande
mais il ya aussi une autre
interprétation qui va dans un autre sens
c'est une interprétation selon laquelle
ce que nous sommes en train de vivre ce
n'est pas tellement une crise des modes
de représentation c'est à dire des corps
intermédiaires mais de la représentation
elle même au fond et alors est ce qu on
pourrait dire que finalement les gens en
ont assez n'en peuvent plus de cette
démocratie représentative dans dans
laquelle est bien les élus font ce
qu'ils veulent pendant leur mandat sans
avoir vraiment répondre en répondre
auprès des citoyens
est-ce qu'on pourrait le dire alors on
peut être tenté de le dire mais en même
temps comme dirait l'autre il n'ya pas
de démocratie sans corps intermédiaires
ça n'existe pas donc il ya peut-être de
façon inconsciente ou pas l'envy d'un
autre régime politique
c'est possible mais lequel mais vous
parlez de la crise des gilet jaune dans
votre livre et de la façon dont emmanuel
macron la traiter finalement il n'est
pas passé par les corps intermédiaires
il était directement parler aux français
il leur fait d'ailleurs alors le grand
débat est un corps intermédiaires en soi
et il y avait un après
oui et il y avait un appel d'ailleurs
aux corps intermédiaires
quel qu'il soit de participer
alors après c'est vrai qu'on la rendra
peut-être dans la technique des choses
dans la restitution il ne pouvait pas y
avoir de parole de corps intermédiaires
mais en fait les propositions tenus par
les uns les autres
dans toute la france si c'est un succès
le grand débat au départ j'y vais au
départ tous a été endossé par des
personnes individuelles mais là où il y
avait effectivement une réponse assez
magistrale est ce que j'explique dans
mon livre
la réponse du grand débat à la prise d
gilet jaune
malheureusement et est réellement
malheureusement on retrouve ça aussi
dans l'analyse de montmelo précédents
travaux de pascal perrineau
mais les restitutions les doléances en
canari sortent des français sont
aujourd'hui dans des cartons dans les
archives départementales
il n'y a eu de restitution réel
contrairement à ce qui est bété
annoncés ou ennemis comme souhait en
tout cas qu'un forage un peu comme on le
fait dans un terrain un carottage de
propositions faites dans un lieu de lady
représentatif mais il n'ya pas eu
d'étude alors que serait réellement on a
vous a peut-être me poser des questions
sur les nouveaux modes d'engagement et
autres et les moyens technologiques au
service de l'engagement mais alors qu'on
a des cheveux start up nation je crois
qu'on peut se donner les moyens de faire
travailler nos startups
dans de la technologie et les faire
réfléchir à la manière de traiter cette
masse extraordinaire de doléances issue
justement du grand débat c'est vrai que
c'est vrai que l'utilisation de
nouvelles technologies pourraient
permettre une autre forme de démocratie
alors on va parler aussi de l'engagement
évidemment et d'avoir un peu de vous
puisque vous vous présentez dans ce
qu'ils voient là j'ai après vous avez
passé une enfance corrézienne un peu à
l'ombre de chirac
oui j'ai précipité je n'ai pas sauté sur
ces sur ses genoux mais je les ai
beaucoup vu
comme corréziens en vacances mais bien
sûr évoluer votre votre père était
engagé politiquement
alors mon père avait fait partie du
content que je parle de lui avoue qu'il
apprécie beaucoup
mon père a fait partie effectivement de
lire perd pas sa création mais il était
dans une commission nationale guide des
mandats à l'époque où dans laquelle
gravitent elle est certain nombre
d'acteurs mais voilà vous était un peu
baigné là dedans c'est vrai et j'ai une
approche au fond très osé titrer qui
doit le channel géographique widder de
la politique
j'étais petit dans une voiture un peu
ministériel fixe et vous même alors vous
avez deuxième et des engagements mais
n'ai jamais pensé à l'engagement
politique pour pour monde y avoir c'est
pas vous inscrire parti à voir des
bandes à vous faire élire à l'inversé
pose la question parce que c'est une
c'est la forme d'engagement presque la
plus évidente tombe mal agir sur la
société
je peux dire c'est pas alors c'est pas
une boutade mais déjà écrire c'est un
engagement au sondage et au presbytère
c'est bon qu'on envoie un missile ou dix
mille ou cent mille les écrire est
réellement et j'avais j'ai vraiment
ressenti un moment donné le besoin
d'écrire ce que j'ai pu écrire dans ce
livre alors en fait si on parle
politique alors vous avez rappelé tout à
l'heure que j'avais était à matignon
sous d'oeil plein puis françois fillon
dans les fonctions qu'il n'était pas
directement politique mais j'ai toujours
été en parallèle de cela dans les
coulisses de la politique
oui mais je tiens à dire que
l'engagement que je porte et un
engagement citoyen qui n'est pas
partisan mais j'ai été dans les
coulisses plutôt de la droite
mon parcours personnel qui le veut et
j'ai été conduit notamment être le porte
parole dans la campagne je le dis
rocambolesque qui est assez assez
compliqué de françois fillon puisque
j'étais son porte parole en charge de
leur présenter vis-à-vis des corps
intermédiaires d'accord voilà la grille
en 2010 est donc en 2010 et réelle avec
les cette compacte d'une auto dont on
sait qu'elle a été
c'est incroyable qu'offrent natale il il
en va revenir sur l'engagement on a on a
compris assez large et vous suggérer
dans votre lit de la mise en place de
chambres de l'engagement alors en quoi
consiste-t-elle ces chantres de
l'engagement qu'il sauve elle encore
oui alors là vous êtes plutôt à la fin
du livre tant il est vrai que j'ai
éprouvé le besoin de me faire un bref
retour n'a bien sûr que non j'ai éprouvé
le besoin après cette campagne
électorale après les débuts du
quinquennat d'emmanuel macron je me suis
rendu compte chemin faisant après des
centaines de rencontres je n'ai rien
inventé et j'essaye de mettre en musique
les constats ressenti de terrain qui ont
été ceux que j'ai que j'ai pu faire et
j'ai vraiment ressenti le besoin de
créer une maison des maisons qui est cet
observatoire français des corps
intermédiaires qui a un nom un peu
suranné on est que nous sommes d'accord
en faisant reposer sur trois piliers le
premier pilier c'est un slogan une
meilleure conscience de la société
civile contre les ruptures démocratique
donc ça résume je dirais l'ensemble de
mon propos le deuxième pilier c'est un
collège scientifique est composé de
personnalités pour le coût de tous bords
politiques
ça va du docteur patrick hébrard un
ancien trotskiste eric rey médecins du
monde avec bernard kouchner ça passe
marie dionet libéral virginie calmels ce
que j'avais beaucoup mais qui était
vraiment très très engagée socialement
et ce qui n'est pas ce qui n'est pas
connu ça passe par un saut montagne qui
président le média participations mais
aussi du syndicat national du livre
il fait donc le salon du livre et au ton
des personnalités de tous bords et qui
sait alors ce sous un angle plus
politique il ya le politologue ce pas
l'oublier quand même pascal perrineau on
a le président de l'école des hautes
études en sciences sociales
christophe prochasson qui sont tous des
hommes vraiment où des femmes libérables
nouveaux puzzles voilà et qui oeuvrent
en fait quand on troisième pilier qui
est un rapport annuel dont vous parliez
tout à l'heure et qui cette année alors
ce fait ne s'agit pas de ce livre nous
aura l'objet par le rapport annuel de
l'ong rapport datent de la nostalgie
ce seront des propositions que nous
sommes en train d'élaborer et qui seront
soumises aux prochains candidats à la
présidentielle un très bien voilà et
donc je n'ai pas remis en question la
nausée dit voilà j'éprouvais le besoin
cesser ces propositions vous faites et
ses créations que vous avez venez vous
proposez là donc la mise en place de
sept champs de ses chances de
l'engagement alors 60 dans l'engagement
c'est une structure de plus parce qu'on
voit pas très bien ce que c'est une
chambre de l'engagement est ce qu est ce
que ça fonctionnerait
oui alors nous ne sommes pas là
forcément dans le principal des choses
en fait le constat ce constat distension
des liens entre la société civile et les
politiques et la solution que je propose
c'est de s'appuyer sur ces hommes et ces
femmes de bonne volonté engagé qu'il
faut qu'ils forment en fait un dernier
filet de secours
quand on se dit qu'on n'est pas loin de
la marche au moment du gilet jaune ou
d'une autre forme de gouvernement qui
sait un jour pardon de mode d'exercice
du pouvoir qui sait on se dit que il est
très important d'assurer la promotion de
l'engagement et à partir de là je fais
tout un tas de propositions qui partent
de constat
donc ça c'est une proposition d'un
paquet qui n'est pas la première frappe
et qu'est ce qu'est ce que c'est alors
ça une chambre dégagements ce peut être
habitué ça peut être abritée pardon dans
les chambres de métiers ou des fonds de
commerce
rénové tels qu'on les attend non l'idée
c'est de pouvoir répondre pas seulement
à la jeunesse qui a soif d'engagement
est acquis pour pour laquelle je salue
cette initiative on a créé ce service
civique national enfin universelle cmu
bien sûr mais l'idée c'est de pouvoir
donner la main à tous ces gens qui ne se
satisfont pas parce qu'au départ
engagements s'il ya une petite flamme
individuel je dire chacun dans son coin
on se dit que là où on est on ne se
satisfait pas forcément de son job sa
seule chance à l'horizon personnel et en
envie de faire quelque chose en plus
quelque chose de plus collectif et de
tisser des liens entre soi même et le
collectif mais parfois le maquis est
tellement large qu'il faut pouvoir
donner les gens la main aux gens pour
leur dire vous avez 2 voilà dans votre
la région vous habitez il y a tel est l
association qui peut être intéressante
telle fondation territoriale ou
d'entreprises
l'accord est l'entité dont il est un peu
léger pour guider les gens qui ont
ensuite dans le magasin justement vous
parlez alors beaucoup des jeunes et pour
justement c'est alors c'est ceux qui
sont plutôt des plus réticents à
l'engagement on voit bien là revient au
vote
cd plus abstentionniste c'est peut-être
dd on voit bien qu'elles aient tendance
à considérer qu' on peut s'en sortir
seul
mais que ce qui se passe collectivement
c'est pas folichon si je veux dire et
comment pour aider à tirer vers
l'engagement et vers quels engagements
alors si je peux me permettre d'être au
fait vous alors oui il y à la
participation des jeunes aux élections
qui est un vrai problème
non car la vie démocratique du pays ne
se résume pas à une élection tous les
cinq ans et mon chantier je place
vraiment méchant que la respiration
justement on peut haïr c'est ça qui
était alors mais il y avait une enquête
je croise philippe sousse pour ne pas
les citer il y a il est à peu près un an
sur l'engagement des jeunes et on se
rendait compte qu'en terminale plus de
40% des jeunes étaient engagés dans des
structures type associations ou ong ou
autre ou partis politiques et aussi des
mouvements de jeunes et un oeil derrière
macron il y en a dans la plupart des
partis politiques dont il ya quand même
un engagement des jeunes mais je pense
que si on pense nouvelles formes
d'engagement pouvant attirer les plus
jeunes générations
je pense qu'il faut aller vers une
individualisation plus grande de
l'engagement que les gens ne se sont pas
noyés qui se faire un peu à la carte
mais malgré tout pas à titre individuel
mais dans des structures établies
démocratique pérenne stable qui
permettent de canaliser d'organiser
l'engagement des uns et des autres c'est
l'idée ça serait d'un peu de guider les
gens qui ont envie de s'engager il leur
donnait des débouchés possibles quoi ça
ça me semble fondamental en
développement des réseaux sociaux
ainsi tout au contraire en ferme ces
jeunes sur eux mêmes ces questions
d'urbanisme entraînements on prend parti
beaucoup sur les réseaux sociaux mais
est-ce qu'on ne reste pas enfermé dans
sa dans sa chambre débattant avec les
autres c'est un vrai débat une forme de
banalisation de tous
j'en ai discuté pour vous gâcher avec le
président de
enfin le patron des patrons geoffroy
roux de bézieux il n'y a pas si
longtemps il disait que le temps où
l'élection d'un grand patron pouvait se
faire du patron des patrons à main levée
et terminer aujourd'hui même petite
candidature au medef d'avoir tout un
retentissement extraordinaire grâce aux
réseaux sociaux
donc ça c'est le bon aussi des réseaux
c'est à dire que ça permet d'alimenter
une bien ce sport est alors sans
reprendre à mon compte les explications
par exemple un aller l'éditorialiste
comme eric zemmour je pense qu'il y a
une forme de crainte chez nicolas
sarkozy il disait aussi dans son livre
de mémoires de l'été dernier une forme
de crainte de perdre le monopole de la
parole alors que ce soit peut-être de la
part de certains journalistes je sais
que c'est pas du tout votre cas mais
mais également du personnel politique
quand chacun peut à toute heure du jour
et de la nuit apostrophé sur une
associée ou non il faut déployer faut
être capable d'en prendre comprendre sa
part ce n'est vraiment pas une question
facile avec une influence sur question
d'âge moyen vous parlez aussi beaucoup
de la question se rassembler autour du
bien commun on ne peut qu'être d'accord
avec vous ça évidemment mais dans une
société de plus en plus morcelé qui est
également tenté par les communautarismes
est ce que la définition d'un de ce bien
commun auquel vous faites référence
n'est pas devenu impossible alors
[Musique]
où je pense que les hommes et les femmes
engagés qui ont envie de faire des
choses pour leur pays porte malgré tout
malgré tous les problèmes que l'on peut
isoler distinguer très facilement
l'actualité nous permet tous les jours
sont porteurs d'un certain nombre de
valeurs qui sont justement celles que
j'entends globe promouvoir valoriser
pour fortifier le corps social
je vous donne un exemple je crois que
vous avez consacré votre vous parler de
mes travaux juridiques vous me permettez
peut-être une assise
je crois vous avez consacré vos propres
travaux à nathalie à la tranquillité
publique
mais que vont ratafia je n'ai pas le
sujet à l'ordre social et là ça devient
le sujet parce qu'au fond
ce que portent les hommes et les femmes
engagées sur le terrain je fais pas de
droits jeudi
c'est ce qu'on peut rattacher à l'ordre
social et ce que je veux vraiment aidé à
faire pour lutter contre tout ce que
vous décriviez à l'instant c'est
permettre à l'ordre social
les hommes et les femmes engagées sur le
terrain dans les associations d'hydra de
se rapprocher de s'imbriquer beaucoup
plus dans l'ordre politique de
rencontrer un peul architecture du
pouvoir d'où toutes les mesures qu'on a
que j'ai commencé de proposer et qu'on
va proposer pour permettre en fait
in fine est de donner un sens et c'est
très important politique de données ne
semble-t-il c'est une des leçons que
j'ai pu retenir de toutes mes rencontres
échanges donner le sentiment aux gens
qu'ils participent à la destinée
collective du pays ouais mais c'est bien
ça c'est un vrai en crise aujourd'hui
quand même hein c'est ça qui est en
crise et ça ça peut passer par un
certain nombre de mesures comme une bête
c'est pas con de 6éme république j'ai
pas de théories fumeuses sur la
démocratie participative
mais on peut par des points
d'acupuncture vous citiez cette mesure
là mais il y en aurait beaucoup d'autres
y permettre au corps social de se
fortifier et alors si on prend un
exemple personnel politique aussi bien
dans le processus menant à la décision
en organisant des consultations un peu
plus large un peu différente de ce qui
ce fait parce qu'on a toujours les mêmes
autour de la table aussi bien que dans
la diffusion une fois que les mesures
sont prises dans la mise en oeuvre des
mesures permettent d'associer beaucoup
plus finement les français arrêtés en
fait
au fond je pense que notre intervention
elle a arrêté de faire la politique en
général et je le ciel une interrogation
qui doit être portée par les hommes et
les femmes politiques aujourd'hui c'est
de se demander au fond si le pays est
prêt à accepter en s'appuyant sur les
gens engagés et bien de donner un sens
supérieur à l'engagement des hommes et
des femmes du pays alors peut-être
aborder un vrai pari
un poids qui est un peu peu en annexe de
votre livre mais qui me taise nous vous
citez l'expression d'armes et des rêves
qui était une expression pour doit à
quelqu'un qui a fait beaucoup de bruit
pour dans sa vie qu on oublie un peu
aujourd'hui peut-être malheureusement et
je crois que vous avez bien que 10 et
jean edern hallier
oui alors je n'ai pas bien connu mais
gelé je pense bien lui puisque c'était
mon premier engagement
d'ailleurs j'y pense en nous écoutant
mais c'est mon premier engagement
bon j'étais certes un peu baigné dans la
politique mais j'étais plutôt des vies
dualiste comme beaucoup de gens au fond
se traduit du rift alors voilà sans
l'engagement
intellectuel souvent est individualisé
le distingue que par les intellectuels
sont engagés les seuls et parfois en
capacité à drainer des gens derrière eux
alors jean edern oui c'est mon premier
engagement parce que j'avais pour son
frère créé le collectif des amis de jean
edern hallier vous avez bien connu
secours à l'époque ce mardi et parce que
je les biens lui j'avais reconstituer
son son cabinet d'archiver ses
manuscrits ses correspondants ses
émissions de télé l'accord est là pour
essayer de faire perdurer sa mémoire
dans une structure organisée dans un
corps intermédiaires au fond et c'est
quelqu'un qui est un peu tombé
malheureusement un peu dans l'oubli feu
c'est un peu dommage parce que c'est
quelqu'un qui coûte ya une autre
personnalité avec une autre personnalité
que vous citez à plusieurs reprises
celle de stéphane hessel l'auteur de
cette sorte de livret qui s'intitulait
indignez vous or justement est-ce qu'on
n'est pas aujourd'hui dans cette société
moi je trouve de l'indignation
permanente
on proteste et finalement la personne
pas grand monde qui propose quelque
chose
alors donc je crois que peut peut-être
se demander au fond pour tours pour
résumer le son peut se voit que pour
terminer notre île conclure au four
dites nous ce que vous proposez comment
vous le résumé riela en quelques en
quelques mots alors c'était plutôt un
livre à la jeunesse nom de stéphane
hessel bas ce serait un d indignez vous
mais en vous organisant sur tout et en
ne tombons pas dans le travers de ne
l'utiliser comme moyen que les réseaux
sociaux quand vous regroupent en
cherchant ce qui vous relie les uns aux
autres en regardant ce qui a été fait
dans le passé pour mieux regarder
l'avenir et dernier un dernier beau
c'est une lettre ouverte avec manuel
maintenant est ce que vous devriez pas
plutôt dû écrire de lettre ouverte aux
français parce que c'était au tour
gasquet alors par deux les manuels
macron alors qui a qui a bien lu le
livre puisque j'ai été les jours de la
parution du livre
auditionné en quelque sorte pendant
longtemps par par l'elysée sur ces
questions là que j'avais déjà été reçu
dans le passé
je pense que c'est un livre qui peut
durer au delà de son destinataire pour
le message vraiment que j'entends porter
pour les français merci moi j'espère
merci n'y avait jamais eu la bonne idée
donc je le rappelle rauzan l'engagement
c'est aux éditions fou merci merci
nathalie
[Musique]